[MUSIC PLAYING]
Competitive diving is
one of the most
beautiful Olympic sports.
It requires strength, ability,
and above all, courage.
Up here on a 10-metre board, it
takes just a second and a
half before you hit the water
at about 30 miles an hour.
And in that second and a half,
the athlete has got to do
complex somersaults, twists, got
to understand the heights,
and got to understand
the angle of entry.
So how does the diver do that?
And that's where the
coach comes in.
So before the diver surfaces
from the water, the coach has
got to come up with the answer
to the question what do I tell
my athletes?
Okay you stopped it well, good
rip, it's a little bit quick.
You should try diving.
I give them feedback
that helps them
achieve their goals.
And that's the goals for that
session, the goals for that
training cycle, and ultimately,
the goals that
will get them towards elite
performance and hopefully an
Olympic medal.
So, Adam, we've worked
together for a
number of years now.
We've installed six cameras,
four force platforms, two
enormous TV screens.
How do you use those to
help your athletes?
Well, we use it to gives lots
and lots and lots of feedback.
And of the different kinds of
feedback we get, we can choose
which ones of those the athletes
respond best to and
make sure they get more
information in that style.
In the first instance, you've
got your coach's eye.
You're looking at them and
saying, internally, that looks
right or that doesn't
look right.
This is why.
And then the iPad and the video
and the force data gives
you a bit more information that
says yes, I was right
with what I thought.
Or actually, this is new
information, so I'm going to
turn that into a postural
correction or a timing
correction that's hopefully
easy for the diver to make
happen to get them closer to
my coach's eye and my data
idea of perfect.
By the time they've come up from
the water, you've got all
of that ready.
You tap your tablet, as
they hit the water.
That goes and grabs the last
few seconds of video data.
And by the time the diver comes
around, they can have
seen their replay on
the big screen.
And then we go into a little bit
of detail with them in a
way that works for them and
leads to a technical change
that makes them a little
bit better.
I think it was more
my legs did that.
They did exactly the
right thing.
It just needs a little
bit of zip.
So it takes that out.
So we've got the video of Ben.
This is the high-speed video
link to the force plate data
and we can play the
video through.
Oh, wow.
I love that
You can see the line projected
on-screen.
And if the line's longer,
he's pushing harder.
And depending on what direction
the line goes,
that's the direction he's
pushing into the tower.
So here, for example, you see
he's pushing back quite hard.
Now the graph, up here, tells
the coach and the diver if
they want it, a, how hard in
terms of Newtons they were
pushing on the tower in two
different directions.
So the green line shows how hard
he was pushing down onto
the tower, the red line shows
the x-direction--
how hard he was pushing
forwards or backwards.
OK, let me just give
that a go .
That is fantastic.
I love that.
So having that, and having on
it here, by the side of the
pool, being able to do that--
that is just wonderful seeing
those force vectors.
So what the top athlete has is
instinct and judgement .
But he needs more.
At the elite level, you need
evidence-based understanding
to get those incremental
changes.
And it's the job of the sports
engineer to take the
measurements, to understand it,
and to impart it back to
the athlete and coach, so
they can be the very
best that they can.
I love it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]